Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je déambule sur scène au milieu
d’un décor démesuré.
Devant moi, des gradins de 800 places,
une tour régie.
Les décors sont montés
sur des rails, prêts à rouler.
Demain, le Théâtre de la Douve
de Saint-Quentin
joue Les Misérables devant 500 personnes
pour six représentations.
(Applaudissements)
Je m'imagine le chemin parcouru.
Mais, que d’émotions !
Quand est-ce que tout cela a commencé ?
Eh bien, à 19 ans,
j’ai fait un stage sur la découverte
des émotions théâtrales.
Pendant une semaine,
dans une salle sans fenêtre, uniquement
éclairée par deux ou trois projecteurs,
le comédien qui anime le stage
nous fait du rentre-dedans.
On crie, on chuchote, on bondit.
On s’éclate quoi ! Tout va bien.
Nous sommes mis à nu.
Des sensations encore inconnues
nous poussent les uns vers les autres.
Au bout de deux jours,
nous sommes shootés aux émotions.
On a presque envie de partir
garder les chèvres ensemble.
C'est vous dire.
Au bout d’une semaine,
quand je reprends le boulot,
les gens me paraissent bizarres,
tout me semble beau, drôle, mais futile.
Depuis quelques années,
je fais du théâtre
dans l’association de mon village.
Après ce stage,
je ne vois plus les choses comme avant.
Alors je décide de mettre en pratique
ce que j'ai appris.
À partir de ce moment-là, c’est moi
qui assurerai la mise en scène.
Je succède ainsi aux curés qui,
quelques années avant moi,
s’occupaient de la mise
en scène et du théâtre.
Depuis 1934.
Il y a du théâtre
à Saint-Quentin-les-Anges
depuis très longtemps.
Même les vieux me racontent que les
enfants font du théâtre dans les greniers.
C’est vous dire.
On a un texte et des chanteurs.
Ce texte pourrait se jouer devant
une guinguette au bord de l’eau.
Ça tombe bien,
puisque notre salle est
tout près d’un cours d’eau.
On ne se pose pas de question,
on a les gens,
c’est quoi le problème ?
Et c’est parti pour deux
week-ends de folie.
La magie opère.
Le spectacle est un succès.
Nous faisons mille entrées
en quatre séances.
Petit à petit, la troupe
du Théâtre de Saint-Quentin
commence à avoir sa petite renommée
dans le département.
On a des chanteurs aussi,
alors on décide de monter Starmania,
renommé « Rêve de star ».
C’est quoi, le problème ?
Là encore, beaucoup d’énergie déployée.
Les copains agriculteurs
arrivent avec leurs bennes,
avec un télescopique pour mettre
en place le pont lumière.
Toutes les petites mains [sont là]
pour les décors et les accessoires.
Tout le monde est là.
Cette année-là, ma femme qui allaite
notre petit dernier en coulisses
rentre sur scène
toujours au dernier moment.
J'ai eu quelques frayeurs quand même,
je vous le dis franchement.
Que d’énergie !
Chacun a sa place et nous partageons
le bonheur d’être ensemble.
Depuis ce spectacle,
les jeunes de nos ateliers disent :
« Vous êtes bien gentils,
vous faites votre show et on n’a rien. »
L’instituteur du village, Jean-Luc, monte
des petits spectacles de fin d’année
et forcément, à un moment
ou un autre, on se croise.
Avec Jean-Yves, un élu,
nous germe une idée :
on va faire un festival
qui s’appellera « Graine d’acteur ».
C’est quoi, le problème ?
Encore une fois, tout Saint-Quentin
est là, de bon cœur et de bonne humeur.
Maintenant, on a
des jeunes, des chanteurs,
des techniciens.
On pourrait peut-être monter
un spectacle de variétés, non ?
Tout le monde est là encore une fois.
On décide de faire un truc caritatif.
On chantera pour une association
différente chaque année.
Il y a à peu près une cinquantaine de
personnes qui viennent et qui chantent,
qui font des sketches.
Chacun répète chez soi et on fait
deux représentations ensemble,
une générale,
et ça roule.
Quelques années après,
on vient nous voir en disant :
« Ce serait pas mal
si vous pouviez chanter un peu
à l’extérieur de Saint-Quentin. »
Et alors ?
C’est quoi, le problème ?
On prend une douzaine
de personnes avec nous
et on part dans toute la région
pendant une dizaine d’années,
à raison de huit à neuf fois par an.
Ah, j’ai oublié de vous dire que de temps
en temps on anime des arbres de Noël.
Un jour,
on a loué un parachute
pour faire croire aux enfants que
le Père Noël sautait de son traîneau
au-dessus du village
où il y avait l’arbre de Noël.
On avait mis un peu de lumière
dans le verger
et les enfants ont découvert le Père Noël,
parmi ses ficelles, assis dans le verger.
Vous auriez vu les lumières
dans les yeux des enfants.
Ah, j’oubliais, on anime la Fête de la
Musique aussi sur la place du village.
Sur une benne transformée en scène.
L’alchimie fonctionne
à merveille entre nous.
Nous formons une vraie équipe.
On se comprend sans se parler.
La confiance est totale.
C'est hallucinant tellement ça va vite.
Il se passe quelque chose
dans ce village du sud Mayenne.
Et en fait, il suffit d’écouter
les gens, de croire en eux,
et ils sont capables
de faire de grandes choses.
Ils ont envie d'aller plus loin,
plus haut.
Ça tombe bien, moi aussi.
Depuis quelques années, dans la tête,
j’ai ce spectacle de Victor Hugo
que je voudrais bien faire.
Mais il me manque du temps.
Alors je tombe malade.
Opération, repos,
chimio toutes les trois semaines,
pendant six mois.
Du temps, j'en voulais, j'en ai.
Et c'est reparti.
Nous sommes en février.
Il faut que je fasse
quelque chose de grandiose.
Et pour ça, il faut
que je me mette au travail.
* Il faut que je [dessine] dix scènes
devant la mairie, sur deux niveaux.
Il faut que je trouve
des gradins de 800 places,
une tour régie de seize mètres de haut.
Et aussi, il me faudra la sonorisation
pour les comédiens.
Mais là, je ne pourrai pas.
On n’a pas assez d’argent
pour acheter des micros ou en louer.
Donc on décide que pendant le spectacle,
la quinzaine de micros qu’on a,
on se les échangera dans les coulisses.
Une sacrée organisation.
Il nous faudra aussi des décors,
qu’il faudra déplacer
ou complètement effacer.
Et il nous faudra aussi 150 costumes.
Eh oui, oui, oui, oui,
c’est une superproduction.
150 participants en costumes.
Un tiers du village.
A l’hôpital,
tout mon bordel est sur le lit.
Les infirmières râlent un peu
mais me disent qu’elles
viendront voir le spectacle.
Elles tiendront [leur] promesse.
Quelques mois plus tard,
le spectacle est dans ma tête.
Les décors seront sur des rails.
Il y aura des effets spéciaux, il y aura
des scènes compliquées à filmer.
Alors ce sera mon fils Mathieu
qui les filmera
et on les reconstituera
sur un écran géant.
On adapte le texte à plusieurs mains.
Toute la famille est là
dans l’organisation.
Le conteur sera Victor Hugo lui-même,
joué par un comédien
qui sera perché à sept mètres de haut.
Les répétitions s’enchaînent
et le planning est serré.
Quelquefois, nous répétons
sous une pluie battante.
Les enfants sont gelés.
Eh bien, ce n’est pas grave,
tout le monde garde le sourire,
content d’être là.
Il me manque la sonorisation,
l’éclairage et les gradins.
Après avoir vu une publicité
sur une route,
une rencontre inattendue me permettra
de régler tous ces problèmes.
Nous sommes en juin.
Tout est prêt.
Ou presque.
On perce, on creuse, on tronçonne,
on coud, on soude,
on monte à seize mètres de haut,
on se jette dans la douve,
on rit, on pleure, on s’engueule.
On mange.
Et on répète.
Six mille personnes assistent
à la pièce des Misérables de Victor Hugo,
sur des gradins,
dans un petit village perdu
dans la campagne.
Hollywood en Mayenne.
(Applaudissements)
Six mille spectateurs.
Tous les habitants, à un moment ou
un autre, ont participé à cette aventure.
Six mille spectateurs, je ne sais pas
si vous vous rendez compte.
La troupe du Théâtre de la Douve
participe tous les ans à un festival.
[Celui] du théâtre amateur de la Mayenne
où participent en général une vingtaine
de troupes sur les 80 du département.
Cette année, elle a remporté
le prix du public.
Vous connaissez les concours des villes
et villages fleuris en France ?
Eh bien, Saint-Quentin-les-Anges
est officiellement reconnu
village de théâtre, ça le fait, non ?
(Applaudissements)
La veille de la première des Misérables,
l’un de mes plus beaux souvenirs :
je suis seul sur scène.
Je pleure comme un gamin.
Je me rends compte du chemin parcouru,
en me baladant entre les décors,
entre ce stage sur les émotions théâtrales
et les Misérables,
il y a un monde,
une passion,
une véritable histoire d’amour
qui déplace des montagnes.
Et aussi,
un village de 456 âmes en Mayenne.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)